data uh in the past used to be you know
bi reporting that you would look at once
a month or once a quarter or whatnot and
you know if it's broken if if the
numbers are wrong uh no worries you take
a few more extra days and and you go and
fix that
right um and that's changing rapidly
today right like modern
tech companies um kind of
live off of their dashboards uh hundreds
thousands of people look at the data
every day to make every single decision
and then
increasingly people are using machine
learning models
to automate decisions and to
do things fully automatically based on
data
[Music]
welcome to 20 minute leaders how are you
i'm good excited to be here today
i'm honored to have you here leor and we
have way too many things i want to talk
about i'm just going to dive in to give
a little bit about your
your bio and then i'll ask some of the
the fun and interesting questions
you know at tel aviv university for
bachelors and masters
stanford mba at the gsp a
co-founder of sukasa which first of all
it's a beautiful name and i have to
learn more about what he did there
uh sold to assault to barracuda
after being backed by excel and inducing
horowitz and first run capital which i
have to ask how
how the hell you made that happen then
senior vice president of email
protection
at barracuda and now the co-founder of
another startup monte carlo
lior this show is for young
entrepreneurs i'm a young hungry scrappy
entrepreneur and there's i i know that
there's so much that i can learn from
you so i really want to make use of
these 20 minutes
so first of all thank you for being here
and second of all tell me
a little bit about about you are you an
engineer an entrepreneur
what are you it's a great question and
i've been going back and forth about
that uh
for a long time now um i'm definitely an
engineer
by training um and
and also i think that that's where my
heart is at
uh but i did find myself uh spending a
lot of time on
on non-engineering stuff because i've
spent a lot of time in early stage
startups and
um and when you do that you kind of get
to do a lot of different things
uh across the board from um
you know from building teams to to go to
market
and also product engineering so right um
i've definitely spent a lot of time
doing
other things as well but uh i'm still
hoping that one day i'll get to get back
to writing code all day long and i i'm
definitely passionate about that
you know i have to say that that is one
of the things that excite me most in
talking to
people like you on the show because you
have somebody here who
you know is an engineer but you know had
such a unique experience both at the gsb
then creating a company
that was sold to barracuda being a you
know a very
very executive manager at barracuda now
another again an entrepreneur but saying
that after all this you still wish you
can go back to writing code because
you're truly passionate about technology
and i just i just love that because i
think it's that passion and curious
which which leads people like you to to
these huge milestones
tell me a little bit about the journey
that you took and some of the decisions
that you've made along that journey
because it's not the typical you know
israeli journey to go to the gsb and
then everything else but
tell me a little bit about what you're
what you've done there
yeah i know it's uh it's been a long
journey
with a lot of turns but uh i started my
career as
uh as an engineer right like i i worked
for a couple of startups back in israel
um you know in my in my 20s
and then at some point there i felt i
wanted
a new adventure uh to kind of broaden my
horizons and and learn things
uh beyond engineering uh and maybe try a
different place as well so that that's
that's kind of what has inspired me to
uh to come to stanford
um and stanford was kind of a
a great experience and a great
opportunity for me because i think it
kind of
it brings together like general business
training and leadership training and all
that good stuff
um along with an environment that's very
tech oriented and startup oriented and
there's
um it's really that the community theirs
is very
vibrant um and very focused around
entrepreneurship and tech so it was a
great kind of combination for me um
so i spent two years there uh i dabbled
with
thinking i might do uh non-tech stuff
like i don't know consulting or uh or
semi-tech stuff like vc
but um but ended up deciding that that i
want to
do the thing that i love best which is
uh startups
and engineering so i ended up partnering
up with with my
um co-founder back then uh he was
a phd at stanford uh in electrical
engineering
uh we partnered together to uh to start
a startup uh company tsukasa in the
cyber security space
um so that's what i did right after
school right after the gsb
where are you you're you're at stanford
you're doing your js you're at the gsb
you're thinking about consulting
or going to vc or say no no i'm going to
be an entrepreneur and
you have a friend phd electrical
engineering at stanford
when what was the moment where you
decided to start this together were you
always talking about creating a company
together
or did you just say okay let's try
something or did you have an idea first
and then join forces
what actually happened there uh
yeah i know i think um i made the
decision independently that i wanted to
start a company
uh it was just too exciting to pass up
[Music]
and i actually um i worked with a
handful of people back then including
classmates from gsb
and you know you go around between
different projects and different
uh ideas and um
and uh they they were in completely
different
uh spaces like one was in e-commerce and
uh another one was actually also an
e-commerce
and then the third one uh was was what i
ended up doing
um with with my co-founder back then
whose name is assaf
um and uh it just ended up being
feeling right right it was the right
team uh it was the right space
uh it was an exciting opportunity in a
space it seemed
uh that to have a lot of dynamic uh
dynamics in it a lot of growth so um so
enough
being kind of the right uh the right
opportunity for me among several that i
explored and
and um and that's something i i would
tell anyone thinking of starting company
um
you know uh it's it's worthwhile looking
through several
different teams if you can and several
different
um spaces and ideas and see where things
stick like where do you get your
passion where do you see customers
getting excited where uh where are
things
moving and changing quickly and um and
and yeah it worked for me so so you
actually ended up spending
just about as much time in barracuda as
you did in sucasa right because you
spent about four years in each of them
a little bit less than barracuda but you
had the unique role of being senior vice
president
of engineering with email protection and
and you know
as a cyber security enthusiast myself
i'd love to hear a little bit about
you know what would you do there and
what is it about
email protection that that it was so
relevant to what you were doing
oh um so uh
bearca so when we joined barracuda but
becca acquired sucasa and
and when we joined barracuda um
we were fortunate to work with some
really really great
leaders there and
um and learn a ton and one of the things
that happened was that we got a
card launched like go and do something
exciting uh and can be whatever you want
right
um and i think
um after three or four years of doing
sukasa
uh we felt that we were kind of
um exhausting if you will the market
um around around what we were building
at tsukasa
and we're thinking like what are some
what's some adjacent fields what are
some areas where we could take the
technology and really
uh build something even bigger and even
more exciting
um and it so happened
that those times where uh were
were times of great need uh in the email
protection space
um so it was a time when uh
various types of highly personalized
phishing attacks
uh and account takeover attacks and
other forms of email fraud
uh were were kind of growing really fast
and we realized that the industry was
uh was lagging behind in terms of being
able to address it and like every time
we spoke to customers they were
uh inundated uh with these things and
and and it started to get into
kind of material uh economic
uh damage uh happening through email
tags
um and so we had this like very
uh unique approach uh technical approach
to solving this problem
that didn't exist back then um and kind
of aligned pretty well with the things
that we did at sucasa so
uh we ended up building and launching a
product
um at the barracuda the product
uh was it was the fastest growing
product for bakuta ever
unbelievable and kind of ended up
leading the market and we got into the
leader wave of forrester and whatnot so
um
for the first time in the company's
history so uh it was really exciting
and it was a very gratifying experience
i learned a ton
both about the technology and the market
we were operating on in and with
email protection um and i also learned a
ton about
you know building uh teams and companies
and
uh and and learning from senior leaders
i have to
i have to admit like throughout my
career before i mostly worked in
um in smaller startups and and i do
learn a ton
right like you learn a lot a ton by
doing and like uh
figuring stuff out and making your own
mistakes um
it was the first time that i was working
for for uh people that were far ahead of
me
uh in their careers and and and i had a
a great opportunity to to learn and
really
uh see how they look at things and how
they do business and
how they lead teams and all that good
stuff
so i stayed for a long time um and
really really enjoyed it
um even when i left i was still very
excited about what i was doing and i
would
i'd probably be happy to stay there as
well uh but end up leaving for an
for an even more exciting opportunity
which is what i did today it's monte
carlo
i love that one key difference from
being the entrepreneur in the room
you know as you're scaling your startup
and then all of a sudden joining and
being senior vice president at a much
bigger company
you know building teams and i'm sure
that building a product within a big
company is very very different than
building a product within a startup
what are what is one or two key
differences that you've observed um
from these experiences yeah i know it's
it's a huge difference
um um i think one
difference uh which which has been
thoroughly discussed in in a lot of
books is is definitely the
the kind of uh some form of the
innovator's dilemma right where
uh the company has a certain momentum
and um has teams that have been spending
uh years and sometimes decades uh
building stuff
uh and that stuff prints money right and
it's selling well
and it's uh it's working great and like
how do you come and tell them that you
know this is
you know you might do it in a nice way
but like how do you come and tell them
that's legacy
uh and that they really need to be
investing in this new exciting thing
that's making no money right now
but will be big one day um and i think
that that's
uh it's definitely a challenge in large
larger organization that where
a lot of people have a lot of momentum
going in a certain direction so
that's definitely something that that i
uh you know you can read about in books
but until you kind of go through it and
experience it yourself it's
it's it's it's hard to to fully
understand
um so that's that's one thing i learned
um the second maybe um
is uh it was definitely a much larger
team in barracuda
so i learned that a lot of
um that really um
it's it's also true for smaller teams
but like culture wins
right every time right like my my job
i could no longer um even fully
understand everything that
that we did right like there's so many
so many things going on i certainly
didn't have any opportunity to
to do things myself but like the main
way by which
i could impact the organization was to
um what was to hire the right people
and to to put together a a
you know a a framework or or an
environment
that that that would make them
successful so
um and a culture so that that was
uh that was huge as well so very very
cool
leo yeah leo we don't we don't have much
time but you know the most exciting
opportunity now monte carlo
uh at first when i saw that you work i
want to call i was like okay is he
building the poker chips that i enjoy
playing with my friends on friday nights
i'm assuming that it's not that i know
that it's all about data so tell me a
little bit about
monte carlo and the decision to leave
the incredible role of senior vice
president barracuda to
again be a young entrepreneur
yeah i know poker chips is definitely
one of the ideas we were considering
uh at the time uh we decided to go for
data
um i don't know time will tell whether
that was the right decision
well see yeah i i don't know it's early
um but uh what we do so
we're definitely in the data space our
customers our
data teams so we help data engineers and
data analysts and sometimes data
scientists
and we help them with um with a buzzword
called
observability uh so it's the idea
of uh of being able to make systems
reliable
and uh i'll i'll try to explain that so
um you know the maybe the way to think
about it is
um especially if you've been engineering
um is you know 20 years ago
uh if you if you even had a website uh
and it was broken and went down uh
nobody cared
right like you might call someone in
marketing to take a look at it the next
day
uh today uh any sort of business is
uh is strongly reliant on on digital and
on
online applications and websites and uh
if something
gets broken um you know someone's going
to wake up at night to fix it
uh and in fact multiple people and it'll
be a ceo level
uh issue right um and we think the same
thing is happening to data right like
um data in the past used to be
you know bi reporting that you would
look at once a month or once a quarter
or whatnot and
you know if it's broken if the numbers
are wrong uh no worries you take a few
more extra days and
and you go and fix that right um and
that's changing rapidly today right like
modern
tech companies um kind of live off of
their dashboards
uh hundreds thousands of people look at
the data every day to make every single
decision and then
increasingly people are using machine
learning models
to automate decisions and to
do things fully automatically based on
data uh
and data is also becoming the product
for a lot of companies right but they
might be serving data to their customers
as
their service and so the
the reliability of that data uh the
accuracy of that data the correctness of
that data is becoming
important um and it's no longer
something that you're
you know you're calling someone and they
might take care of it a few days later
it's something that you need
you need to take care of in real time
you need to make sure your data is
reliable
um and in the same way that there's a
lot of methodology in software
engineering a lot of tooling
um you know tools like datadog and new
relic and
app dynamics uh to manage you know the
reliability of applications
uh we're helping teams with managing the
reliability
of their of their data products of of of
reporting
models of um of analytics
um so that's what we're working on today
i love that lior it's such an exciting
journey what are some of the biggest
insights that you're taking with you
from sucasa
in the early stages now to monte carlo
you know things that
if you hadn't done tsukasa you probably
wouldn't know or you wouldn't believe
if others would tell you yes
uh it's a good question i i hope i
learned a few things
um the main one i think
um i think it's tsukasa um
one of you know looking back in
hindsight is 20 20.
um we did um we were building
essentially a security layer for dropbox
dropbox back then was was taking hold
and
i was becoming very popular and we felt
that businesses will need ways to secure
dropbox and make it
more appropriate for confidential or
sensitive information
um so that's what we were working on
um it was an exciting opportunity we had
kind of
early success and uh and got
and and we pretty much dominated that
market we were we were
uh dropbox's number one partner and uh
and if you needed security for dropbox
sucasa was your
your go-to solution and uh and it was
all very exciting
um however i think that we were so
focused on that uh specific niche in the
market
is that we overlooked
uh even larger opportunities that
existed back then a category that that
was
later that later became caspy uh was
happening back in time and we could have
we could have gone into that category it
was a natural extension of what we were
doing
um and we didn't we were super focused
laser focused on
on optimizing for our niche and i think
what i what i
and that ended up being a mistake right
like the caffeine market ended up being
much larger and much more
um much more interesting uh
over the long term um and i think what i
learned from that was
um you know you have to be
laser focused on what you're doing make
your customers happy make one customer
happy then make 10 customers happy
etc and
at the same time you want to be
attentive uh to to what's going on
uh and be willing to change course and
and expand
the definition of what you're doing um
and and and and and see where things are
going and where the
kind of broader market is is shifting um
and i think that's one of the biggest
things i took away like
at the end of the day if you want to
build a really large company and that's
our goal with monte carlo
we're here to you know to build a a
unicorn or a deck of corn or whatever it
is
uh an industry changing company and to
do that
um you really need to
see things in a broad way it's not
enough to build like
a feature or like highly satisfy a very
narrow need you kind of need to build
a cat in this case we're trying to build
a category so that's
that's kind of what i took away to keep
your eyes open to
category building opportunities that end
up being much more exciting
i love that lior thank you so much for
the time and you know how busy you are
and i appreciate it so much
this is an insightful and it's an honor
to have you here
what are three words that you would use
to describe yourself
oh wow uh it's a great
uh question um
i'm probably um
i i've been told right um i don't know
how to describe myself but i've been
told i'm
i'm quiet so that's that's one thing
i don't speak much um
i've been told i'm fast i do things very
fast
and and and that's been helpful in my my
entrepreneurial career sometimes it's
more important to be fast
um and i've also been called stoic
so stoic uh that's it for you yeah
i love that lior thank you so so much uh
really really great i appreciate you
taking the time to do this and stay safe
and stay healthy
hey you too michael great talking to you
thank you very very much